Wow
mom do something someone do some what is
this huh
what is this I don't like it yeah I'm
actually [ __ ] it's hard it's mirrored
okay
watch it ace [ __ ] I'm actually [ __ ]
Oh No okay wait I got it this thing ah
that's what's gonna happen t-series how
dare you how dare all of you I never
been this upset in my life I didn't
think it would have to come to this but
I'm gonna have to pull out the big guns
I'm gonna have to pull out the artillery
I'm gonna have to do the worst thing
I've ever done and I'm suck dick no I
haven't okay we've gotta make it to the
Super Bowl is the Super Bowl tomorrow I
think it is it's not the start at the
end it's the beginning of the beginning
we are just getting started so what if
we're just 40 can't wait who can't who's
counting anyway I'm not counting
counting is for [ __ ]
Einstein biggest [ __ ] of them all
Stephen Hawking's a flat out flat B for
John alright this ends now the beginning
ends now and then it starts again they
will never pass us as sure as this chair
can do this
nothing oh Jesus Christ that scared me
I'm still alive we're gonna keep going
forever
up until the Starz TV series there this
Super Bowl II today guys we need to last
no [ __ ] place I know mr. B's has
something in store for us okay please I
beg of you please I can't do this any
longer we need to fight more now than we
have ever fought and before oh my god
why is my green screen so far that way
hello watch this guy's
[Music]
but that's what happens see series
that's right everyone I'm not sparing
any Smurfs see at this point I'm going
all out yeah I think I just punched
myself whatever okay doesn't matter
nothing matters okay
I mean this matters I mean you guys
don't understand
we need to bomb I'm just kidding we need
to we need to just I don't know what we
need to do right all right I don't have
a plan I have one plan you guys are not
gonna like it
and trust me I don't like it either I've
waited until the very last moment to
pull out this card because I didn't want
to be here I didn't want to do this I
didn't want to sink this low
play for a night well you guys already
figure it out
disparate times calls for desperate
measure minutes which is why I am going
to play for night with named Joe nugget
that's in line well I will play for
tonight I don't really know how you play
for tonight and ever played for
I don't want to play for tonight I guess
it's the only thing that will stop
t-series the only thing that could
possibly do the trick I keep you 2
million if you okay cool I'll take it
perfect time for Super Bowl egg what the
[ __ ] are you guys talking about actual
brain lets in the chat congratulations
everyone the stream is lagging we'll
seriously mom get a new computer loser I
don't know why I'm roasting you guys I
need your help more than ever I'm the
kid getting kit ok I'm sorry
play all the popular games throughout
the year so while we're starting on
fortnight I figured out how to [ __ ]
play this game
just give me one moment I need to hack
the Hatton mainframe okay that's the
sound of my hacking I think it's working
[Music]
okay oh god yeah oh god what have I done
John please forgive me okay I didn't
want to do this I didn't want to sing
solo there's times you just gotta take
one for the team you just got to do what
you got to do
now wait isn't in to keep its thing he
keeps it here there we go
I can't believe I'm doing this
I feel disgusting I'm already given
frame requests dad damn you guys yeah
guys not have friends do you guys not
have mobile phones okay what is this
co-op he why the [ __ ]
it's battle royale I think that's what
it is I think that's what all the kids
have been talking about is this what you
want look what you they got a little
person hello in there why okay what's
that [ __ ]
[Music]
what if I quit gun lobby why the [ __ ] am
i warm
what
I guess we'll do swine
I have literally neck literally I've
never played this before
[ __ ] that's annoying I was news about
the change in the settings I can't
believe you've done this
how could you commit for tonight side
how could you have done this
there was a marshmallow event oh well
I'm sorry I missed it
geez why did I not play sooner all right
just let me play [ __ ] out so the RIT
the name of the game is that you drop in
a low blow pop yeah that's it pick and
landing spot and search for gear okay I
mean I play my fair share of video games
don't cross shut the [ __ ] up all right
ain't got time for your silly means at
this point all that matters [ __ ] all
that matters is what's up there that's
all that matters
okay now why the [ __ ] is it snow what is
this unrealistic standard on video games
[Music]
account info epic account ID I'm sure
that's fine it that's out there how to
import friends how to decline yes
how to hide yes probably should have had
that filter mature language oh heck no
oh god sorry guys
hello guys can you hear me [ __ ] where
are they jumping polar Baker all rhyme
there boy I'm there so that's a tiny
little oopsie there on me but bad things
guys can you hear me Mohammed hey
Mohammed can you hear me I don't think
they can hear me guys
let me show it I'm playing with a
Chinese and a Muslim and a Swedish this
should be good I'm going down here bros
I gotta say that the graphics are pretty
epic
this game it's not so bad so what do I
do in this game right this is literally
literally I see something shiny I'll go
right okay I got slurp why am I so slow
how do I run okay I build so I would see
all right I run with [ __ ] hey I got a
gun all right
and how do I use the gun dude like I'm
think I'm ready to Mohammed I think I'm
ready to go pro pursuit yeah Wow okay
what do I do with the pursuit gun Chris
for free that's cool how does that work
okay
gee I hope nothing bad happens this is
pretty exciting guys this is the world
premiere everyone has been waiting for
this why watch the Superbowl when you
can March this [ __ ] [ __ ] I actually
know what mr. B's is going to do in it
it's pretty epic okay
basically they hired a bunch of
prostitute and bought a bunch of cocaine
that's all I know really
Germany invaded Poland oh [ __ ] no that's
not good
did I thank the bus driver of course I
did what if stupid quite alright how do
i chat with my [ __ ] teammates
okay so holy boys chat on we should talk
no okay hey Mohammed what are you doing
listen here we need to strategize right
now or else we're screwed me soil please
hello this is not going well
me soil does he not hear me what is
happening all right god I forgot I'm
actually playing the game all right I
remember now you've cut down trees and
[ __ ] to like get wood right because I
would kind of need that to get up there
this is not wood maybe I can write it
no okay [ __ ] I genuinely have never
played it I honestly have no idea I
don't even watch the streams I've seen
this I think I'm ready to go pro all
right so then yeah I can build sub right
yeah okay well now we can get up here
easy okay all right this is not really
what I [ __ ] won anything me saw it
pocket why is it so hard to walk oh the
[ __ ] Mohammed is there now
go up in the zipline all right good tip
the last time you played a Valerie out
shut up okay I don't need the
reminiscing right now what we need is
subscribers all right
has this made any difference whatsoever
it is working guys for tonight is
working
[ __ ] it I'll take it I'm expecting you
to win me too I mean so far my KD is a
hundred percent
oh no the storm is sinking I think this
is just like Minecraft hey me saw it me
saw it Nihao no that's all the Chinese I
know
god damn it we're screwed a miso miso we
sold my pants I mean you did goddamn it
is there any point of day in and day out
jesus [ __ ] christ
whoa
my team [ __ ] sucks dude useless team
what are you doing well how many what
are you mama do it someone tell me what
Muhammad Muhammad alright don't come
complaining to me Muhammad hey we did
that me so it don't ever do that again
alright I will [ __ ] you up me soil
listen to me me so I'll do something I
can't get up there
drink the slurp why does that give me a
shield holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm Pro I
figured that out all by myself
Muhammad I swear to god Muhammad let's
[ __ ] prank man can I get a team that
talks to me
what kind of morons plays a multiplayer
game that's right I'm calling my team
morons it's the only way for them to
understand don't want to do with oh [ __ ]
look at this oh yeah a guy either
okay okay hey why does drop my glider in
your eyes oh yeah yeah and then a still
you so trifle okay very nice very cool
I'm doing pretty good
my fortnight mic is on yeah I know cuz I
want to talk to my team [ __ ] out but
my Tim doesn't talk to me I'm on voice
check I know I'm a voice chat you
frickin Fricks oh my god he's working
keep subscribing bros it's working keep
subscribing as long as it's working I'll
keep playing [ __ ] jump on there the
rope on this set line oh of course I
knew that
okay oh [ __ ] I said [ __ ] enemies over
the ah shoots a sweetie hey the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
good job Muhammad good job my man you
[ __ ] did it now then yet are these
genomes
Hey look at skin star like I'm not
playing games over here me soil your job
me soil knock themselves out [ __ ]
some cereal I to team what am I supposed
to do now shoot back that's just
ridiculous out of ammo
okay well that's part of the plan don't
worry brush a lot of people don't know
about this like that this is just like
Lord of the Rings when Gandalf and the
team tried to oh god I think that was a
waste this is a [ __ ] sniper
okay I'm then bye
it's okay all right I know my like
dilemma fine okay look at this a trap
I'll build a trap
[Applause]
okay we're good okay
one sweet with low HP versus [ __ ] off
god damn it
the storm is shrinking well so is my
penis what the [ __ ] is this oh [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah really glad I took those AEK
shots before those really good use
bandages are [ __ ] I have been this right
cool I'm figuring this guy and game out
all by myself so this is how you know
you're a gamer ago a gamer proud already
says you can only heal up I knew that I
was just testing the system
all right how well can they hear in the
game and [ __ ] like that will they hear
me talking hello
don't shout okay cool I think we got an
agreement I think we're on the same page
it'd just be so anti-climatic to dine
now cuz i just ran around like a [ __ ]
idiot
alright so i guess blue is better than
green men are mammals what okay how does
it feel to like watch an actual good
player for once in this game I bet you
guys watch like he's done that streamers
don't know what what that [ __ ] is a
balloon dude I got [ __ ] balloons boy
oh [ __ ] god it's just the greatest
game of all time holy [ __ ]
I got [ __ ] tooth oh no no no I didn't
want this what the [ __ ] is this stop
stop what the [ __ ] I don't want balloons
dumbass game what are you I got cut by
balloons
so worst game I have ever seen balloons
are made by taste I knew it I knew it
this is not what I want I want controls
all right once I scroll through it
oh [ __ ] push-to-talk tea at the very
bottom this game people play this with
controllers on a PC alright it's fine
we just warmed up we're barely getting
started at least I died from balloons
and not some pathetic gun or getting
outplayed at least balloons I can
respect at least if I die by balloons I
can at least be like okay well you know
what
well played balloons you did good holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] we are destroying t-series
I bet they're sitting there crying right
now they were ready to pop the champagne
well not today t-series and we got more
where that comes from as well
[Music]
dori incarnate thank you very much
arigato gozaimasu and oh [ __ ] 9999 put
fortnight in the title troll troll ah
which you're a goddamn genius God can
you shut up please I'm trying to
strategize fortnight I'm so stupid I
didn't put poor night into the title a
Cheeto turn off your [ __ ] mic hello
hello
Oh Lemmy will fish push the talk just
put it up thank you what be much but
yeah I just got Spaniards in this game
now I see how it is t-series are
recruiting so far
this has been a wife's experience oh my
[Music]
Viva españa can you believe the audacity
of this guy
how could he changing the name of the
stream playing for at night to stop
t-series parentheses yes I'm that
desperate okay
saved Kofi Channel
you're the best hello from Russia hello
back coffee thank you very much
play some pub gee that's more fun
oh well it's pubs you're gonna get me
subscribers and no I don't think so okay
so fortnight at [ __ ] is do you think
I want to be here do you think anyone of
us wants to be here
I don't think smart Oh God
hello hello why the [ __ ] are you
whispering [ __ ] actions okay
are you guys any good at this game much
yeah great all right we'd rather you let
it go what do I want to go what do I
want to go [ __ ] no not sold to Springs
whoever [ __ ] mark that dren T you
best not drop okay look frosty flights
[ __ ] nd dead to me okay how do I thank
this bus driver [ __ ] I didn't think I
didn't thank you bus driver [ __ ] up
nine-year old army more like
five-year-old army I forgot that kids
play this game yeah guys I got about a
hundred wins in this game just listen to
me and follow me and we'll we'll win
this all right
can't tell if it's someone like doing a
weird cosplay or an actual [ __ ] fear
adults playing this game hey what the
[ __ ]
what gun is that
oh did I just die my banjo some Bank yes
I think I know that
no don't do it don't do it you'll regret
it do you know who I you best not throw
a [ __ ] ball at me no oh oh
two plus two is four what else you got
okay
[Music]
oh thanks diamond say watch out get him
a [ __ ] diamond what are you doing
gosh damn it darling you'll regret this
okay you're it's okay oh yeah I forgot
you can get stream snape did I just get
stream tonight
ban him report him right now everyone at
the games hey I think I singled fired on
an assault rifle to the house so
confused
put streamer mode you can do that what
does that do alright I guess I'll have
to do that I'm too good at this game
people need to cheat to beat me alright
whatever like whatever it's whatever I
don't care if anyone do that again gonna
be Superman filter Auto received gets
cold mode why am i laughing at night
sorry
a loud background push-to-talk some type
of brightness
[Applause]
are you guys making [ __ ] up aim assist
of course they have a missus hi we're
dropping how's it going team oh my god
Oh radar he's at 50p no it's going pick
all right we got stream snipers all
right I don't know how to do this I
guess you technically have stream
snipers to oranges
all right place in Park that's yes
just kidding ghosts no bshorts not be
shirts listen I'm Pro okay just listen
everyone protect me and you'll be fine
you're the only one with me with the
[ __ ] dude and come in oh yeah well you
better
it's okay I've got this have a gun is
that not a team play no it is okay here
here Watch shield yeah oh thanks broski
this will not be forgotten
okay so do I have like the [ __ ] weapon
is I was happening in there [ __ ]
everywhere what do I do
Hey
marshmallow fan account is with us guys
it should be fine I [ __ ] hear someone
be careful the things of those coming
yeah I think so too
be careful I say dude he must be super
pro he like build I don't even know how
to build yeah you're using a spray
weapon he might not hit listen I'm Pro
okay that's right how do I get weapons
it's fine I know what I'm doing
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] screwed guys thanks I
need ammo
someone do something I'm done I means
I'm down yeah oh okay nice so like I'm
not sure you like marshmallow and this
big marshmallow and Fortney yeah
marshmallow marshmallow you piece of
[ __ ] sorry less melty series how dare
you even ask that question they're
really good
don't make me perma ban you're right I
know the developers of this so this is
your first step play it no it is I mean
it may be
don't ever find me here it's okay
marshmallow marshmallow fan got it's why
you can't rely on marshmallow fangs so
the guys it's alright and we've all just
crawl my way to victory thanks bro
done with T series that's right
what a bold statement down with why am I
such an [ __ ] okay let's do another
one
we're warming up on level 2 9 I'm level
2 guys
getting better I'm getting exponentially
greater at the speak very things by the
end of this stream
I'm gonna be a gamer gone a long time
how did streamers do it
anonymous oh well you should have
[ __ ] told me turn shadows off makes
the game smoother
that's all his own it's [ __ ] settings
and [ __ ] anonymous mood and shadows got
it keep subscribing
we're 60,000 away yeah alright oh my god
sake keep going
it's a Christmas tree thank you no no
now listen here you dropped Elton your
fan for life getting PewDiePie we need
to go to this salty oh my god oh thank
you listen - and who is play to tame
dommage
I think I know what I'm doing Paradise
Lost alright don't ever question me
again oh [ __ ] I'm pleading with
beautifly
oh my god they're literally my god my
everything
I'm your everything you might know thank
you for clarifying
I mean Oh My yes that's right I'm
praying ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hey the
[ __ ] is this guy's problem
marshmallow get the [ __ ] outta me
piece of [ __ ] marshmallow I hate to say
it - marshmallow bite [ __ ] idea whatever
you say okay oh my god I can't believe
this oh my god I knew you'd know my bag
I'm coming
No enjoy enjoy the game goodbye all
right this is Felix in the kitchen
getting myself a drink
this is ASMR and you're summertime with
feelings I can't believe that you're
still stuck dating me that's just okay
hey I need to win this for boots do you
think I didn't go to the bathroom or
something realizing I'm wearing a long
line
did anyone say anything bad while I was
gone
raro win the game no need
yo where's not I told them not to say
okay good all right well good luck
okay bye Mikey why do you call me
oh boy oh boy
well let me tell you guys we're doing
great
all right t-series is getting absolutely
destroyed as you can see here by the
straight-up facts and logics okay
t-series can eat my nothing okay I
should put delay on the stream that's
what [ __ ] nerds do and don't know how
to play this scheme by a skin that's her
[ __ ] nerds do I don't know how to
play this news right real pros played
too full
Scooby got waves remember these words I
should hide the screen all right I'll
hide the screen this time this way they
don't know where I'm going
all right now they know now they won't
know what I'm dropping Andy what's up
Andy stop doing that please
it's embarrassing
and II for the love of God please stop
that [ __ ] is wrong with my team I remove
this oh you are the real cutie pie
ah yes oh nice to meet you nice to meet
you too listen here we gotta win this
okay you don't sound very conveyance we
conclude with Judah pang well good
yeah go time what okay
they have no idea where we're dropping
why am I so big in the stream it's so
that I can drop I gotta make myself
smaller [ __ ] I'll just be here
[ __ ] I [ __ ] it up [ __ ] it up
and we're going here no one else is
going here
everyone is going everywhere what the
[ __ ] it's just how dude I got a sharp
what is this shape
Marsha Bella do something this is going
for me that [ __ ] ass hole the streams
knife idea really worked out oh god I
mean what a [ __ ] I was saying [ __ ]
let's move the game alright nobody gets
to see the game that [ __ ] way to the
game go
I lost the air it okay listen I know
what I'm doing [ __ ] I got a battle past
- you're up what the [ __ ] is wrong with
my character why do you look so goddamn
dang
who made that face alright alright
broski's we're just gonna have to do
right one there we go it's alright hello
yes PewDiePie hey hey hey APD fun yeah
you know you and I you and I go to a
bridge you know yeah let's go bro
oh yeah or re bro uh right there bro
we're mark it on the map I'll be right
there
all right we'll meet up there so all
right bro how long are you gonna extreme
for how did you know I'm straight so
extreme sniped you oh my god bang I'm
recording you give me a band now like
the past four games I've played everyone
the lobby leaves immediately custom not
in the game
no one [ __ ] shared me this time okay
with streams i bowl you want but at
least do something happened is really
entertaining under stream i like your
screen rose would you say it's our
favorite yeah I unsubscribe from ninja
because I subscribe to me people
obviously that's a mechanic and I had
some do you just goes to that screen bro
it brings tears to my eyes hello
artistic it is did you say artistic yeah
like you put so much work into that like
getting it to play all the setup it
takes life I know many China yeah oh
yeah yeah [ __ ] is this
I don't like this hey hey listen a [ __ ]
oh yeah nice sorry night you all right
take the Bistro you got it
thanks let's go do you think a lot of
brofist into the game absolutely
[ __ ] is all the loot there's like no
loot here oh alright alright
you and I you and a fly do I want to fly
yeah in a car okay let's go this one up
here yeah there's one up here right my
horsey its sky [ __ ] with me alright
boom oh we can't see the game boo hoo
hoo you guys are crying oh this ain't
this ain't good
this ain't good Oh God
yes yes
all right where's the flying car I think
you're ready to go pro all right come
here over here
if right it fell down the show he
[ __ ] with me
can you angry fly what are you doing no
no I can fly bro I don't know where it
went
I it's a little formula it's right here
you found it oh yes
all right bro
all right
you're ready for this it's gonna be got
waves No
you know
Oh God can I hit control so I can drive
all right you ready all right do it I
might not be able to say long do it do
it
Wow oh my god
all right I'm gonna flip that was
awesome I knew those an epic hero in the
photos
it's based the boost and yoga vest
Oh
yeah I'm pretty good at this
it has a phase tried to sign you yet
have the reached out to you every single
client has reached out thing yeah I
don't know why you're even asked yeah I
assume that [ __ ] they're not gonna shoot
from that I understand of this [ __ ]
game works put on a shield what I did
I'll show you where this chest is gonna
see you the secrets the University ready
break that break that dresser break that
dress Wow alright any of this good
that's a sniper and unless you slice my
brace for cowards alright yeah why is no
one at tilted towers I thought this is
like where everyone goes okay we're
going here is that good tactical shotgun
yes
I like how someone just gave me the tip
to press R to realize there's a lot
better not constrain flavor yeah pick
the shop I have a live a campfire it
yeah it'll kill you if you're not on
full health I got to heal a little bit
well you can see that it's gonna pull
help
Oh what would you Davis this is saying
here it's very safe I love your chest or
tail she wrote justice
all right come here jump on this ramp
get it up there chess there's a pistol
sniper you grab it yes not very good all
right all right we're gonna we're gonna
go eliminate all the people and get the
epic victory ROI all right which one is
better tell anyone
promise yeah I won't tell anyone by the
way uh yeah except for the 300,000
people watching but yeah I won't tell
anyone okay so we have a dealer one oh
yeah yeah
I don't know the dealer's what's the
deal here I never got I wait the real
man Oh all right we're just gonna that's
gonna change all right what's better a
shotgun or this pistol Oh what the [ __ ]
is this rift go what is this thing
all right yeah
right here someone
alright what are we doing
got away with the gas goes oh I got him
nice stream sniper here take the shield
you got a heal
oh you're after yeah oh the other guy
laughs good Zeus
use a TCU spy okay first there's a chest
down here
I think I'm playing with someone that
knows how to [ __ ] play
there's gliders so if you fall from a
high place you can use the gliders and
you won't die okay all right all right
hey launchpad yeah you don't need to
drop something to pick it up okay it
goes for your same slot as a trap yeah
we're gonna when the storm gets too
close will use the rip to go and we can
go to the safe area
[ __ ] I'm such a plane I have no idea how
you play wait do you have another
campfire I'm looking for something to
kill you come down I'm gonna try and
find some medical items in this pawn
shop thing
there's a big still diner come drink it
there you go doko desu got where the
[ __ ] is he hey I'm in the come in the
building
come downstairs I have feeling for you I
can heal you come on right here
pick that up take that shield up Thanks
aim got a user if you go someone's
coming
hold the hold the thing and then left
click this one yeah hit space to a
glider just say if they're longer though
[ __ ] I'm playing you sure got a it to
avoid them legit that they're bad come
to come down to this man listen to this
dude oh god they spotted us it's fine
it's fine
listen listen there's another shield
thing you can't drink it them alright
come down into the divot and we can hide
so we can win and get the yeah yeah
but do carry me though yeah it's gonna
be a little hard I have 120 ping I'm in
the US China oh my god how could you do
this why the [ __ ] my health not going
on why not get it back
oh you got a fine healing this guy's
that [ __ ]
that's why I came down here no one will
be here and we can just look around to
find something that's the idea
actual nine-year-old carrying me how
about that all right still in it for an
excellent
so like worst ninja in this game Yola
he'll be the last opponent obviously but
uh I I've seen her gameplay you'll
obviously I'll play him okay
like you come back to me so no one
attacks you without me yeah what are you
that how far away is a teacher is right
now there's a team in front of us these
there's really far away oh yeah I think
they hit me okay come with me come o me
[Music]
I'm at three help so like you no good
here the ultimate track come here come
here okay pick that up and right click
alright hold it then right oh yeah this
is gonna be they'll never find you like
this let's do it alright for [ __ ] sake
it's snowman oh god [ __ ] that I know
it's over I should have gotten with the
satellites right
it's fine
by the way few if you ever died you're
shown say that I know if you ever dies
you tip don't gotta we gotta blame it on
streem snipers I promise
I know that every time to matter okay
call me phone escaped
god damn straight zhaibar [ __ ] stream
snipers
do something around tea serious wins I'm
scared it's not going for me don't worry
don't worry I got something ok I'm back
so we never lost I actually lost me
there
all right we gotta we gotta steep did
you like a change you're beautiful
screen from a black your actual game I'm
still black you do God that's why
there's so many people Oh God lemonade
these people sell winning oh yes just to
make it interesting
no I thought you said you were proud my
fingers your fingers what happened
it lay escape read I escaped and then
what do I hit exit I feel bad it was
very nice for helping me but no I don't
want to add right on sister
listen I was my third game I'm level
four by the end of this dream I will
have victory real no matter what it
takes to stop T series they're getting
absolutely destroyed Haiti series ha
that's what's happening that's what
happens to t Series Europe excuse me one
sec it just check in my phone
okay I'm getting private calls oh geez
wonder where that could be all right
let's do this
did I just I just cover myself up
instead of the game don't worry about it
I was gonna change Europe to America oh
my god listen listen listen it's all a
diversion you will never be on my level
you
I've done my prayer oh my god are you
cutie yes you are you subscribe
yes on how many accounts - okay good
[Laughter]
that means we can play good job yeah
would you consider a third ik what what
do you mean maybe
don't act me okay where should we drop
all right let's keep it a secret
we gotta use taxes yeah sorry so like
just like on it
there you go okay they'll never expect
that just don't say it outline
okay just don't tell people we're going
to happy Hamlet okay yeah I know the
screen is black okay let me just land
and then I can play my epic ninja
fortnight stream all right and get the
epic royale these goddamn [ __ ] stream
snipers want to suck my peepee that's
right
pipi I call my penis pipi you got a
problem with that why am I so slow
[ __ ] move
I'm hanging in a bit low I don't think
good bra gonna make it
listen if you die you have to subscribe
to PETA fly on another account okay okay
we got a deal okay yeah deal yeah I need
blood that sounds like a yes yes okay
okay
don't forget what you promised alright
I'll hold you to it
okay three hours later I [ __ ] landed
all right guys listen if you're gonna
swing tonight's fine but at least help
the boy out all right I never got a
victory oh you really want to stomp on
poor innocent Swedish man playing for
tonight since I'm goddamn desperate
sorry I mean since I have no other
choice
so where's a ninja in this game he's
probably on the American servers Oh
Frick dude all right well can you tell
him like to come and play hi I wish I
could I have this for you you can if you
drink this you have a full shield now
why would I do that
oh there is someone Meyer it's one
it's probably what I say stream sniper I
don't kill him
okay oh there's another one
I heard him alright don't kill him don't
kill him
we're friends we're cool right alright
don't shoot
alright yeah yeah we're cool hey rest
your friend we're getting an army are
there a lot of people
[ __ ] this takes forever all right we're
all good all right they got it that's
right that's right that's what I'm tired
they're coming all right together we'll
we'll win this game all right
finally we got oh [ __ ] I mean today hey
if we work together okay we're gonna get
the victory
we're gonna get the victory else see
that's what I'm talking about someone in
limited sub two beards right now with
the pistol
[Music]
in squash say I don't even know how you
dance
that's how busted much of a point - hey
how do you dance
if you click B and then your bracelet
ring I would never stink so all right we
got to win follow me my fellow stream
snipers I gotta be assuming again
ninja if you're watching this dream
don't report them okay they didn't do
anything
there's another one another one for the
army one another one joins the team he
got the dance of our people he's with us
so technically if we can get everyone to
be a stream cipher then we can guarantee
to win this all right you good the dance
of our people I actually like to only
have a [ __ ] pistol just avoid the
bridges and we have this in the bag
oh there's another one all right let me
eight let me jump on let me jump on oh
they're a lot of people here yeah
there's even a [ __ ]
we are going to witness I know
we have an old army oh my god relax I
mean yeah we have an art
Oh John I'm dying pet there's old
vehicles running the old dog heading our
day this is how for tonight was meant to
be played every yeah everyone in one
squad
someone's sitting at shooting how
[ __ ] dare you
dude I'm just a snowman all right let's
go
right this should begin everyone is
coming to this place yeah
[Music]
we're going for the rial boy for the
race
we're crash-landing protects pewdiepie
at all costs
please as long as Peter pine lips will
be okay listen don't shoot the film in
oh no I know what happened someone's
like me all right I'm sorry yeah listen
I'll revive you don't worry all right my
stream sniper hey we got John wick in
the chat that's right
the song of th pion sorry you'll be all
right stop complaining
yeah sorry without it yeah good attitude
you're gonna get nowhere
really [ __ ] shooting
[ __ ] dare you
listen I gotta revive my boy no I'm
sorry man I tried I really tried
can i friend you for absolutely okay you
need to yeah friend request got it
one more we're going for the Ray Allen
to prove our dominance over t-series to
show that we're superior in every single
way hot Jukes mr. Pyatt I humbly ask for
you help my friend oh yeah
[Applause]
I thought I'd turn shadows up all right
guys stream Seibel you want but don't
[ __ ] you will be forever reborn I said
yeah if you shoot PewDiePie it's not
gonna be worth you'll be rewarded a
hundred virgins if you help read if I
win the game where's the dance on my
people actually it's better if the
stream cyphers don't come right away did
I drop it or something I don't have any
gills
[Music]
Zehra that's everyone just me listen do
you think I'm a [ __ ] gamer then a lot
of mute people knew your microphone dude
right there
[ __ ] that all my stream cyphers go
brother Jesus Christ can you not play
alone that was a bit harsh I'm sorry
god dammit
one last game to rule them all one last
game to show my dominance over t-series
press escape and press the speaker I
better off dying anyway
yeah
next game I should play roblox you're
probably right I probably should turn
off motion blur you handsome Swede hello
thank you no I like motion blur I think
it makes the game better thank you oh
god we gotta face the East Asian player
Alex
what is happening
hello hello hello what's up bro how is
it going
you know very good thank you oh very
nice
I know oh okay everyone that stream
sniping we're going fatal fields okay
this is how we win the game if all 92
people are straight already going pay
the penalty they are dancing scatter how
do I feel thank the bus driver actually
let's go let's go let's go bro
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] area
I think everyone in here all these
people man
it's a camp from very pretty feet to it
sorry I said I'm sorry
all right no shoot no [ __ ] idiots
I'm trying to be diplomatic and nice god
damn it
I guess there's no way huh boomers
what was I expecting when lights game
everyone [ __ ] more cool and didn't
shoot each other
change your skin so people can recognize
me I'm not gonna buy a skin like a
goddamn virgin okay
we're in the endgame now this is a we
actually it actually worked
like I think the sub gap was 40,000 or
30,000 now it's like 80,000 so very good
keep subscribing that's the only reason
I'm playing this game just to be clear
just so we're on the same page here
what's the time six sorry do I hear my
own stream there's what the [ __ ] do you
play on xbox are you kidding me I'm done
I'm literally nothing
I am literally nothing please don't just
gonna have your system and that we need
to win this I can't breathe I can't
breathe
oh my god no no I can't breathe okay
shut up come on you need to pull
yourself together god dammit lucky
landing lucky landing oh [ __ ]
you know what I [ __ ] up happy oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I miss out solutes yeah oh my gosh I'm
getting so many messages I'm [ __ ]
dead oh my god my heart is pounding out
of my chest
oh my god [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] dead you got
a guy waiting oh my god other so many
people I know yo yo yo yo PewDiePie you
donated 50,000 thank you so much yeah
that was supposed to be the game for the
wind bros what the Frick we may have
lost the battle but we have not lost the
more the war one last game got Derick I
feel it I feel it don't worry
actually I shouldn't so pretty lame oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I got a go oh uh all right
I forgot I have an appointment I'll see
you guys later
thank you for joining thank you keep
subscribing that's all I ask
keep subscribing be free